HéHélènene Buzzetti, Paul Journ,
LuLuc Ferrandez, bonsoir.
JeJe vous fais tout de suite
enentendre M. Dubé, il dit que
l'l'heure est grave, il y a trop
dede monde dans les hôpipitaux,t
ceceux qui pensent qu'on peut
alalléger les mesures, oh là l ,
vovous êtetes dans le champ.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre, Sané
etet Services sociaux, Québec
- - On est en train de parler de
prprotocole de priorisation, là.
T'T'sais, je vous le dis, là,,
lala situation dans les hôpipit,
sisi les gens ont pas compris,
enen ce moment, qu'on est rendus
auau bout du rouleau, là..
OnOn est rendus vraiment
auau maximum de l'élastique
ququ'on a pu tirer. Il manque
enencore 12 000 personnes
dadans le réseau qui
titiennent ça à b bout de bras,
pupuis vous pourriez êtrtre
lala premièrere personne...
lala prochaine personne qui
a a besoin d'aller à l l'hôpipi,
sosoit pour le COVID ou soit
popour un bras cassé, fait que
jeje comprends qu'il y a des ges
ququi sont tannés, mais pensez
auau réseau, puis pensez à t tot
lele personnel qui tient ça
àà b bout de bras depuis 22 moi.
JeJe pense que les gens vont
pepeut-êtrtre prendre un petit
pepeu de recul puis dire :
"O"Oui, on aimerait ça, rouvrir,
mamais attendons un petit peu."
- - Vous avez compris qu'il n'y
auaura pas de réouverture bient,
d'd'ailleurs, ce qui a fait dire
auaux députés Vincent Marissal i
didit : entre les envolées
jojovialiste de François Legault
etet la situation catastrophiqu,
leles Québécois ne s'y retrouvet
plplus les chiffres sont là, , y
a a beaucoup d'hospitalisation,
HéHélènene, est-ce que ce plaidr
esest efficace encore?
- - Je ne sais pas, je pense que
leles gens sont un peu mêlélés,i
unun peu l'impression du but
babackup M. Legault qui nous
paparlait de la lumièrere au bou
tutunnel et M. Dubé est en train
dede nous dire que cette lumière
esest peut-êtrtre celle du traii
s's'en vient. On a de la misèreà
s's'y retrouver, mais la réalit,
c'c'est qu'il n'y a personne de
boboule de cristal pour nous
prprédire la situation pour
popouvoir nous dire : regarde, n
fafait tout cela étant quelque
sesemaines, on va pouvoir relâcr
leles mesures. On se gèrere ence
bebeaucoup à l la petite semain,
mmêmeme à l la petite journée, n
cecette matièrere, je ne suis ps
cecertain qu'il puisse s'en allr
auautrement.
- - Paul, quand le minisistre d:
lele guide de priorisation a été
mimis en place, pas exécuté ence
lala Docteure nous disait tout à
l'l'heure que ça peut vouloir de
ququ'on va tourner les coins
roronds, c'est son expression,
ququ'on va dire aux gens : alle-
vovous ans plus tôt,t, alors c't
drdramatique au final ça ne l'et
papas?
- - C'est plus dramatique non,
écécoutez, je sais que la semaie
dedernièrere, on entrevoyait
imimpossible pique et on disait
quque peut-êtrtre bonne nouvella
meme redescende, mais la seule
cecertitude qu'on a, c'est que a
fifin de semaine dernièrere état
cecensée êtrtre l'pire et en ce
momoment, on a seulement un
raralentissement de la croissane
dédécadent l'hospitalisation et
c'c'était avant le retour à
l'l'école. Donc, on avait notre
pipire fin de semaine et on ajoe
unun facteur de risque, donc ça
alallait mal et ça risque d'allr
enencore pire ou à t tout le mos
dede risque de prendre un petit
bobout que ça s'améliore. Alorse
pepense que ce qui nous a été
prprésenté aujourd'hui était à a
fofois beaucoup plus réaliste et
dédéprimant que ce qu'on laissat
enentrevoir la semaine dernière.
- - J'avais une hypothèsese. Jee
dedemande si M. Legault n'a pas
fafait... adopter un mododèlelee
gegestion à l la floridienne, c-
àà-d-dire : puisqu'on n'arrive s
àà r réduire le nombre de morts
paparce que les gens sont morts
sosont des gens qui sont des
pepersonnes très s âgégées et qt
bebeaucoup de comorbidités, donc
dedes problèmemes qui précèdedet
cecelui de la COVID, grave, ou
alalors des gens qui ne sont pas
vavaccinés. Donc, d'accepter un
nonombre de morts plus élevés
popour réouvrir l'économie, pour
didire : maintenant on a un taux
dede vaccination extraordinaire,
onon a eu des mesures parmi les
plplus durs au monde et on est
ararrivé à r réduire le nombre e
momorts, alors on va en prendre
nonote, on va ouvrir un peu
l'économie, on va notamment
pepermettre le retour en classet
lele reste va dépendre du vacci.
VoVous êtetes vacciné, vous aves
chchances de vous en sortir vous
n'n'êtetes pas vacciné, vous avz
momoins de chance de vous en
sosortir. Vous avez des problèms
dede comorbidités vous à L Lévis
momoins de chance.
- - Des statistiques, tout décoe
dedes chiffres, nos analyses
dédécoulent de ce compte présene
lele nombre d'hospitalisations,
343417, si on veut revoir le
tatableau, il y a une vraie
auaugmentation de 36, soins
inintensifs, 289. Mais là, , ce
mamatin, Dr Marquis et d'autres
didisent : oui, mais les décès,9
dedes ce qu'on voit, il y a
bebeaucoup de ces décès s qui st
papas décidés à c cause de la C,
ilils avaient la COVID et sont
dédécidés pour d'autres raisons,
cocomorbidités, etc. C'est ça qi
fafait que par son envie de
reregarder le verre à m moitié
plplein, d'autres fois, on le
reregarde à m moitié vide.
- - Oui, effectivement, c'est
vrvrai, mais sur cette question
quque abordé, le modèlele flori,
pepeut-êtrtre que dans les mots,
c'c'est ce que l'on dit, mais
c'c'est quand mêmeme pas ce quen
fafait encore sur le terrain. O,
l'l'école rouvre, mais les
cocommerces sont encore fermés,
leles salles de spectacle, on
esestimait autant de contraintes
dadans les rassemblements, etc.
DaDans les faits, on a encore ue
gegestion quand mêmeme très s se
dede cette pandémie, ce que je
trtrouve...
- - la plus serrée en Amérique.
- - Je ne poserai pas de jugemet
paparce que je n'ai pas évalué..
c'c'est très s serré, effective.
CeCe que je trouve quand mêmeme
inintéressant dans ce plan de
prpriorisation des
hohospitalisations qui nous est
prprésenté, d'ailleurs que vous
avaviez un invité... une station
ququi mentionnait un médecin, on
nonous dit qu'il faut peut-êtrte
rerepenser les soins que l'on
prprodigue, pour êtrtre pilote
auautomatique. S'il y a quelque
chchose qu'on va peut-êtrtre
apapprendre de cette pandémie,
c'c'est peut-êtrtre de repenser
nonotre approche; notre systèmee
sasanté beaucoup basé là-d-dess,
onon soigne souvent sans trop se
poposer la question jusqu'au
dedernier souffle, et peut-êtrte
ququ'on devra en arriver là,,
ararrive avec une approche un pu
plplus critique par rapport à
ququels soins en pratique et pa,
etet en ce sens, je trouve que e
plplan est inquiétant pour ce
ququ'il nous est en ce moment de
l'l'état de la situation, mais l
amamorce peut-êtrtre une réflexn
ququi devrait se poursuivre bien
auau-delà d de la pandémie.
- - Quand la Docteure nous a dit
ququ'on devra, on n'est pas foré
cocomme ça, le personnel enfanté
n'n'est pas formé comme ça, on
dedevra tourner les coins ronds,
pepeut-êtrtre agir différemment.
IlIl peut aussi avoir du bon là-
dededans.
- - Oui, ça a du bon en sens on
évévite le pire, puis cette
réréflexion ne vient pas du
popolitique. En Floride que c'et
unun qui essaie e de faire plaià
soson électorat, le retour à
l'l'école, c'était entre autres
rerecommandé par les pédiatre.
PoPour ce qui de la nuit façon e
trtraiter les patients l'hôpipi,
c'c'est la... qui a lancé le
dédébat. C'est sa façon de trour
cocomment vivre avec le virus en
mimilieu hospitalier et dans les
sosoins, donc on accepte de ne s
êêtrtre parfait, de laisser entr
unun petit peu plus le virus à
l'l'hôpipital, d'avoir peut-êtrn
pepeu moins de patients, retour
plplus rapide du personnel
sosoignant parce qu'on se dit
ququ'il ne faut pas voir...
paparfait avec les soins prodigs
auaux soins prodigués...
- - il faut apprendre à e enleve
nonos têtetes le risque zéro ete
momoins parfait, c'est ce qu'ele
didit, c'est ce qu'on dit.
- - C'est vraiment dans
l'l'organisation des soins en
mimilieu hospitalier, puis là, n
totombe vraiment dans une questn
ququi relèveve entre autres de
l'l'expertise de l'FMSQ, mais
c'c'est vraiment eux qui ont laé
lala réflexion, puis il semble
êêtrtre content de ce qui a été
anannoncé aujourd'hui.
- - J'imagine que ça va êtrtre e
réréflexion très s nuancée parce
cece qu'on reproche au systèmeme
sasanté avant la pandémie, c'est
jujustement d'accepter trop peue
papatients à l l'hôpipital et ds
rerenvoyer trop tôt.t. Il y a ds
popoursuites à n n'en plus finir
cocontre les hôpipitaux. Ici coe
dadans les autres pays, mais ic,
onon est au Canada, avec l'Irlae
etet Israël, le pays qui a le
momoins de lits par habitant ete
loloin, c'est-à-d-dire que la Fe
enen a deux fois plus que nous,e
JaJapon trois fois plus que nou,
dodonc on a un modèlele où il ya
dédéjà t très s peu de lits, ont
dede la médecine ambulatoire. On
lalaisse les gens le moins
popossible à l l'hôpipital. On s
didit qu'on va laisser encore
momoins. On soit obligé de le
fafaire pendant la pandémie, mas
onon doit se poser des questions
trtrès s larges est-ce que c'esa
seseule solution son assez de
lilits, est-ce qu'on doit
popoursuivre cela après s la
papandémie.
- - La question a été posée au
miministre aujourd'hui : est-ce
quque dans tout ça, élément
popositif, ce qu'il va y avoir e
réréflexion, pas une réflexion,
unune réorganisation forcée du
sysystèmeme de santé.
- - En fait, le Clémentine, mais
c'c'est comme un virage
amambulatoire qu'on nous présene
auaujourd'hui, qu'on nous laisse
enenvisager. Une statistique
dédémonisaient imagination
cocontredit que 13 % des persons
hohospitalisées en ce moment sot
dedes hospitalisations
alalternatives, des
hohospitalisations de gens qui
n'n'ont plus vraiment besoin
d'd'soins aigus, des plateaux
tetechniques comme des hôpipita.
1313 % c'est beaucoup, que font-
ilils encore à l l'hôpipital? Oe
àà r ramener cela à 5 5 %, on dt
ququ'on livrait peut-êtrtre quee
60600 lits supplémentaires qui
susubitement seraient disponibl.
MaMais quand mêmeme, pourquoi 1,
c'c'est beaucoup. On en parlaite
pepense la semaine dernièrere, n
mementionnait par exemple que ls
CHCHSLD et les RPA refusent
paparfois le retour de certains
papatients qui étaient à l l'hôl
popour d'autres problèmemes, mas
ququi ont eu la COVID. On ne pet
papas l'accueillir à n nouveau e
ququ'on a peur qu'il déclenche e
écéclosion. Ce que j'ai à d dev,
c'c'est : est-ce qu'on va pouvor
foforcer dans ce nouveau plan ls
CHCHSLD et les RPA a accepté ces
papatients? Va nécessiter beaucp
dede coordination québécoise.
- - Tour de table... vous parliz
dudu modèlele floridien, qui à
l'l'extrêmeme, comme dit Paul, h
cocowboy, mais il y a le modèlen
EuEurope, en France, en Grande-
BrBretagne, où on a décidé...
cecette expression nouveoutil,
mamais de vivre avec le virus.
QuQuand on entend la conférencee
prpresse, ce n'est pas demain
mamatin qu'on va annoncer la
réréouverture de plusieurs lieu.
- - Non, absolument pas. On n'et
papas rendu là. . Juste un
cocommentaire rapide, puis en ce
momoment on est juste en train e
cocolmater les fuites du réseaue
lala santé et on pourrait
sosouhaiter que la pandémie nous
foforce à f faire une réflexions
lalarge sur l'administration des
sosoins de santé, mais j'ai
l'l'impression c'est -1 réflexin
ququ'une réaction constante. On
vovoit que ça fuit, comment on
pepeut régler le problèmeme à ct
teterme, c'est comme si on avait
jajamais les moyens entre autres
enen personnel de pouvoir essayr
dede réfléchir de façon... sur e
lolong terme. On n'en est pas
enencore rendu là, , pas du touu
cocontraire, on se prépare plutt
àà l la prochaine qu'on appréhe,
cecelle du protocole de triage,
mmêmeme si on n'est pas encore
rerendu là..
- - Je faisais l'exemple, je
poposais le parallèlele avec la
FlFloride pour une raison bien
prprécise, depuis quelques jour,
onon a le mêmeme nombre de mortr
hahabitant que la Floride, au
tototal dans la pandémie, la
FlFloride deux fois plus que no.
MaMais maintenant, on a le mêmee
nonombre de morts mêmemes avec s
leles efforts qu'on a faits.
DoDonc, la question se pose de
didire : est-ce que ces efforts
poportent des fruits en ce momet
sisi à c cause de micro, à c cau
vivieillissement de la populatin
dede la cause de la comorbidité?
EsEst-ce que le fait d'ouvrir
l'l'économie attende impact quea
susur le nombre de morts? Pour
l'l'instant, on n'a pas la répoe
àà c cette question.
- - Docteur Boileau a dit qu'on
trtravaille parents police parce
ququ'il faut avoir cette répons.
TaTant qu'on n'aura pas cette
réréponse claire, est-ce que par
exexemple on calcule mal? La
ququestion que vous posez de pls
enen de gens vont se poser, este
ququ'on fait tout t ça pour avor
fifinalement le mêmeme bilan qua
FlFloride, que Paris, Londres,
d'd'ailleurs?
- - Il faut faire attention pare
quque toutes les populations ne
sosont pas pareilles, ça dépende
nonotre âgege, est-ce qu'on ests
vivieux, jeune, en santé, etc.,
alalors les comparaisons sont
didifficiles, et donc il devient
imimpérieux de dire est-ce qu'on
peperd notre temps à p perdre» ?
OnOn ne sera jamais parce qu'one
pepeut jamais faire de scénarios
paparallèleles, si on n'avait ps
fefermé l'économie, est-ce que e
n'n'est pas encore pire?
- - Justement, si on ne fait pas
cecela pour rien et malgré tout,
çaça va aussi mal ici qu'ailleu,
çaça veut dire que si on le
fafaisait rien, ce serait pire t
popourquoi ce serait pire ici
ququ'ailleurs? C'est pas positif
popour le Québec.
- - OK, M. O'Toole, on écoute, i
didit que les libéraux par grand
frfroid dans quelques mois vont
fefermer le robinet du pétrole.n
nene pourra plus se chauffer ni
coconduire.
QuQui est le plus déconnecté
esest-ce que vraiment les libérx
veveulent couper le robinet du
pépétrole dans 18 mois?
- - J'espèrere pas parce que je
chchauffe au gaz ici. Clairemen,
M.M. Guilbeault a oublié un mot
dadans cette entrevue, il disait
ququ'il allait abolir les
susubventions aux énergies
fofossiles d'ici 18 mois, il a
fafait l'ellipse du mot subventn
etet donc les conservateurs se
sosont amusés à l le prendre au,
etet va faire disparaîtrtre toue
l'l'énergie, nous allons tous
momourir de froid. C'est une trs
grgrande malhonnêteteté
inintellectuelle. Le fait que M.
O'O'Toole joue dans ce jeu, ça
dédémontre qu'il ne sait pas
vrvraiment comment camper son
leleadership ou alors il nous
prprend pour des idiots.
- - Ou alors il est prêt t à die
n'n'importe quoi pour une campae
dede financement, mais je pense
quque les hypothèseses Hélènenee
s's'excluent pas, au contraire,
c'c'est un peu tout ça. La
pepersonne qui sèmeme la divisin
cece moment au Canada, d'Erin
O'O'Toole parce que s'il est
sésérieux, il est en train de
prprouver qu'il ne l'est pas, sl
veveut vraiment tendre vers
l'l'carboneutralité, on ne peut
papas continuer à p produire des
enen plus de pétrole et produits
dede plus en plus tout en
prpromettant de polluer moins. e
ququ'il faut, c'est avoir un pln
etet essayer de rallier les
prprovinces de l'Ouest aux autrs
prprovinces avec un plan commun
papancanadien pour réduire les
émémissions tout en aidant les
pepersonnes qui vont êtrtre
afaffectées par cela dans
l'l'secteur pétrolier.
- - Erin O'Toole parle à s sa be
quque l'on se rappelle qu'au
lelendemain de l'élection en
seseptembre, sa base lui a
bebeaucoup reproché d'avoir
rereconnu la validité d'une taxe
cacarbone, d'avoir reconnu la
nénécessité de garder le déficit
pependant 10 ans et d'avoir le
trtroisièmeme point, je m'en
sosouviens pas, m'échappe, maisa
babase lui en voulait beaucoup
d'd'avoir fait un virage
cecentriste. Alors il profite
d'd'une journée froide pour parr
àà s sa base, pour dire qu'il et
enencore là p pour défendre
l'l'économie de l'Alberta et le
pépétrole de l'Alberta de la
SaSaskatchewan. De mêmeme que ce
hihistoire n'aura pas de suite
paparce qu'elle n'a pas de prise
dadans le reste du pays. On